Fifty-four years after Disney brought Mary
Poppins to life on the big screen, the magical
British nanny is back!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm comparing Mary Poppins Returns
to the 1964 classic, revealing the biggest
differences and whether it's a worthy sequel.
When Julie Andrews made her film debut as
Mary Poppins over half a century ago, she
lit up the screen with her take on author
PL Travers' no-nonsense nanny.
I'm sure it must be daunting for any actor
to step into Andrews' practically perfect
shoes, but if anyone's the right person to
slip on Mary Poppins' very particular footwear,
then it's Emily Blunt, who's repeatedly shown
what an incredibly versatile and meticulous
actress she is.
This latest version of Mary Poppins isn't
exactly the same as the original movie and
it's certainly not an impersonation of Julie
Andrews either.
Blunt took her Poppins cues from the character
PL Travers created in her books, which means
she's somewhat sterner, sharper, and ruder
than in the first film.
And then, there's Mary's new accent, which
I wasn't sure about when I heard it in the
trailer.
But, pish-posh to that, quite frankly, as
when I saw the film, I've gotta say the accent
wasn't an issue for me.
Yes, Blunt has gone many times posher than
her own Received Pronunciation, or Julie Andrews'
for that matter, but her performance sold
her clipped, heightened tones, inspired by
British royalty, and made it work in the 1930s
context of the film.
As for the song-and-dance numbers, Blunt looks
like she's having a total blast which makes
watching her a real joy.
So, while she takes her Mary in a different
direction to Andrews, each actress is beguiling
in the role in her own way.
And just seeing Mary Poppins come floating
down through the skies once more may well
bring a tear to your eye.
In the original Mary Poppins, Dick Van Dyke
was such an absolute ball of energy as the
all-singing, all-dancing chimney sweep, street-artist,
and one-man-band Bert that he practically
burst off the screen.
Though a new addition to the story, Lin-Manuel
Miranda's character Jack the lamplighter is
given a brief backstory woven in with the
original characters as it turns out that he
used to be Bert's apprentice.
Van Dyke's larger-than-life performance as
Bert is so memorable that it's a really tough
act to follow, but Miranda is an accomplished
musical performer and plays Jack with a good
deal of charm.
In fact, Jack not only inherits Bert's child-like
wonder and optimism, but also his interesting
take on a Cockney accent!
"As I live and breathe!"
Miranda's attempt is a touch better than Van
Dyke's though he's helped by the fact that,
unlike the 1964 film, the sequel opens with
Jack singing rather than speaking, so the
faulty accent doesn't hit you quite as immediately.
"Comical poems suitable for the occasion,
extemporised and thought up before your very
eyes."
Speaking of Dick Van Dyke, he makes a very
welcome return in the sequel!
This time, we're told that jack-of-all-trades
Bert is off travelling in 'parts unknown'.
So, instead, Van Dyke makes a cameo as Mr
Dawes Jr, who also appeared in the first film,
though played by a different actor.
In fact, Mr Dawes Jr is the son of former
Bank Chairman Mr Dawes Sr, who was the second
character Van Dyke played in the original
film!
And, let me tell you, it really is amazing
to see the 90-something-year-old actor singing
and dancing with incredible gusto once more
and, amazingly, he looks pretty much just
like he did when he appeared as Mr Dawes Sr
in full old-man make-up back in the 1960s!
With the sequel taking place around 25 years
after the original movie, the Banks children,
Michael and Jane, are now the adults of the
story.
These days, Jane follows the activist path
of her mother, and Michael works for Fidelity
Fiduciary Bank, just like his father did before
him.
Also, much like his dad, Michael's problems
and preoccupation with work mean he's lost
his child-like joy, and both films are about
getting that back and appreciating your family.
While Michael does lose his temper with his
children, similar to his father, overall,
he's less stern and markedly gentler with
his kids, and also much less prim and proper
than his dad.
Ben Whishaw brings a lovely, delicate touch
to the role of the grieving Michael and his
performance of the melancholy song, 'A Conversation',
proves a real tearjerker.
And Emily Mortimer is delightful as Jane,
mixing can-do spirit with moments of shy sweetness.
So many of the songs composed by the Sherman
Brothers for the 1964 movie became well-loved
classics still remembered fondly by children
and adults today.
Whether it's the Oscar-winning Chim Chim Cher-ee,
A Spoonful of Sugar, Supercalifragilisticexpialidocious,
Jolly Holiday, Let's Go Fly A Kite, or Feed
the Birds, if you're watching this video then
you likely know at least the tune if not a
good number or even all the lyrics of those
songs.
Obviously, following the Sherman Brothers
is a tall order then.
Still, Marc Shaiman and Scott Wittman, who
composed the musical Hairspray, have done
a top-notch job capturing the tone of the
original movie and recreating the kind of
tunes that reflect the style and era.
It's tough to say if the songs are as iconic
as the originals, given how many times we've
heard those in comparison, but many of them
are definitely very catchy and others certainly
grow on you.
My favourite song among the new batch is 'A
Cover Is Not The Book', which is a dazzling,
humorously innuendo-laden vaudeville number
brought to rollicking life with spirited performances
by Emily Blunt and Lin-Manuel Miranda.
As well as the fast-paced fun of 'Trip A Little
Light Fantastic', 'Can You Imagine That?',
and 'The Royal Doulton Music Hall', we also
get the delightfully lilting '(Underneath
The) Lovely London Sky' and the heartfelt
lullaby, 'The Place Where Lost Things Go'.
And although the new cast don't perform any
of the songs from the original movie, you
will hear traces of their melodies carefully
woven into the score at several suitable points
throughout the film.
Mary Poppins Returns is a real love letter
to the 1964 movie made with obvious affection
by all involved.
In fact, it reminds me in some ways of Star
Wars: The Force Awakens which likewise re-kick-started
a popular property after a long absence.
But, is it as original as the classic movie?
Well, no, in many ways it can't be because
it takes us back to a place we already know
and reminds us of that throughout with numerous
echoes of the original film in story beats,
characters, visuals, and songs.
But director Rob Marshall and screenwriter
David Magee's nostalgia-filled film does manage
to put enough of its own twist on things and
finds added inspiration in PL Travers' various
Mary Poppins books.
Of course, there are so many wonderful moments
of magic in the 1960s movie, from Mary and
the children tidying the nursery, to Uncle
Albert's airborne tea party, to the Step In
Time roof-top dance sequence, and, of course,
who can forget the artful mix of live-action
and animation where Mary, Bert, and the children
jump inside a chalk drawing of the typical
English countryside?!
Mary Poppins Returns also has some appealing
magic scenes, including the children's bath
time which turns into an underwater fantasy
and the sequel's take on the Step In Time
scene is a fun reverse of the original where
the children go down in the world via a London
lamp-post rather than up on the rooftops.
Best of all though is the gorgeous Royal Doulton
china bowl sequence which features a raucous
music hall and mixes live-action and hand-drawn
animation.
And I also really love the genius touch of
having the characters' clothes appear hand-painted!
In fact, Oscar-winning costume designer Sandy
Powell's work throughout this movie is simply
stunning.
While the sequel does gift us special appearances
from Dick Van Dyke and Karen Dotrice, who
played Jane Banks in 1964, sadly, the original
Mary Poppins, Julie Andrews, doesn't appear
because, according to the movie's director,
she didn't want to distract from the sequel
being "Emily's show".
However, we do get a charming cameo from another
screen legend, Angela Lansbury, who makes
an appearance as the Balloon Lady, a character
from PL Travers' books.
Lansbury even gets to sing a song in her inimitable
style, and her presence in the film feels
practically perfect especially given her musical
history with Disney, starring in their live-action
film Bedknobs And Broomsticks and the animated
Beauty And The Beast where she voiced Mrs
Potts and memorably sang the title song.
Another new addition to the sequel is Meryl
Streep's character, Topsy, who, like Lansbury's
Balloon Lady, is adapted from PL Travers'
books.
This is Streep's third film with Emily Blunt,
following The Devil Wears Prada and Into The
Woods, and she's clearly having a ball totally
hamming it up with a deliberately OTT accent
as Mary's eccentric cousin.
Streep's appearance in the movie includes
a deliciously jazzy showstopper called Turning
Turtle, and the whole scene feels like a fun
call-back with a twist to the first film's
laugh-filled, floating scene with Uncle Albert.
By the way, I've got a video about all the
sequel's easter eggs which I'll link to here
and in the video description.
At times, Mary Poppins Returns is a little
more melancholy than the original; after all,
Michael has lost his wife and the children
their mother, and they're about to be evicted
from their home.
In that respect, it's similar to another recent
musical sequel, Mamma Mia: Here We Go Again,
which, coincidentally, also starred three
of this film's cast.
Nevertheless, there's still plenty of uplifting,
cheery fun as well as hope and happiness to
be had with Emily Blunt's Mary.
Sure, bringing the magical British nanny back
on screen after over 50 years' absence is
no easy task as generation after generation
has grown up with Julie Andrews' classic performance
and watching that movie feels like getting
a big old hug.
But, if you let yourself experience the sequel
with the kind of child-like wonder that Mary
Poppins advocates, then you'll likely enjoy
its genuine warmth and delightfully old-fashioned
appeal.
It certainly put a big smile on my face!
And I'll happily watch it again and listen
to the soundtrack as well!
Now, how do you think Mary Poppins Returns
compares to the first film?
And what are your favourite moments or songs
in the new movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
Tap left to watch my Mary Poppins Returns
easter eggs video, or tap right for another
Mary Poppins video you're sure to like.
Congratulations to the winner of my Ralph
Breaks The Internet giveaway.
Make sure you contact me so I can send you
the prize.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate a
thumbs-up and a share!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!